beaucoup de gens se demandent où on va
parce que on constate une très grande
combativité sur le terrain le phénomène
vraiment nouveau c'est les reconductible
qui fonctionne c'est l'entrée en lutte
de nouveaux secteurs de la production ou
l'entrée en lutte par exemple des
éboueurs a beaucoup impressionné tout le
monde et il faut savoir que ce sont
beaucoup de secteurs des petites payes
et par conséquent c'est un signal qui
est donné que tout le monde est très
déterminé puisque même ceux qui ont si
peu sont prêts à leur risquer pour
l'action donc ça c'est la la situation
générale dans notre côté ce qu'on voit à
l'Assemblée c'est que le pire de la
combinaison et à la macronie continue
c'est-à-dire qu'ils essayent de rouler
tout le monde en faisant des promesses
des paroles creuses et là ils sont en
train d'essayer d'en tortiller les
républicains qui sont là comme une
espèce de de
bagages accompagné qui attend qu'on les
descendent du train là et ils essayent
de les rouler à la commission mix
paritaire donc c'est un moment où la
bataille est sur deux fronts semblait
jusqu'à demain et la rue jusqu'à ce que
le retrait ait lieu ne croyez pas que à
part le retrait ou un vote où on les bat
à l'Assemblée nationale le mouvement
soit en train de de ralentir ou de se
poser des questions sur lui-même
ah si si on n'en sait rien vous savez il
y a des moments où on peut prévoir genre
j'en suis d'accord mais là tout le monde
sait qu'on fait du pas à pas je lis ce
qui écrivent vos collègues bon personne
ne sait ce que va être le résultat
demain parce que beaucoup de gens se
posent des questions y compris dans des
secteurs où on les attendait pas un
certain nombre de républicains se disent
que c'est trop parce que quand il rentre
dans leur permanence c'est bon c'est pas
il y a pas que les bourgeois qui votent
pour eux donc les autres disent on en
peut plus on veut pas faire deux ans de
plus quand même pas perdre de vue de
quoi on parle on parle de faire deux
années de plus de travail obligatoire et
pour beaucoup c'est plus parce que ça va
repousser là je de départ à plus tard
donc si vous voulez rien enlève du fond
de l'air c'est extraordinaire tension et
angoisse de gens qui se disent je
tiendrai pas le coup je pourrais pas
c'est ça qui est le fond et la puissance
de ce mouvement voyez-vous
entre la mairie de Paris et le
gouvernement qui sont français de la
position de la NATO par rapport à ça
tout va bien si elle est con je suis pas
avec elle donc quitte à laisser les
poubelles les adores de la grève c'est
absolument incroyable ça alors eh ben il
y a une grève ça arrête qu'est-ce que
vous voulez c'est pas fait pour un
faciliter les choses la grève
demandez-vous plutôt pourquoi les gens
font grève c'est ça qu'il faut se dire
bien sûr c'est pas plaisant vous
trouverez pas une personne qui va vous
dire ah c'est génial quand il y a des
ordures partout mais la vérité c'est que
s'ils ne le font pas personne n'écoute
ce qu'ils disent or tous ces gens sont
dans des métiers où on souffre au
travail et où deux années de plus et
c'est pas rien mais ça ça veut dire pour
beaucoup d'entre eux qu'ils les verront
pas la suite de ces deux années j'essaye
de dire ça de manière à la moindre
dramatique possible mais vous savez tous
bien que c'est ça le fond de l'affaire
à quoi ça sert maintenant
oui parce que les médias sont très
organisés pour faire pression pour dire
qu'il se passe rien qui va y avoir des
violents qu'il y a pas de grève enfin
vous êtes tous les malheureux salariés
d'une machine à propagande donc c'est
vrai qu'il y a des questions à se poser
mais
et la raison Laurent Berger de dire
comment on doit parler comme on doit
expliquer que ça vaut la peine de
continuer la lutte parce qu'il y a des
copains qui sont dedans qui sont en
train de continuer le combat et qu'on
doit être solidaire c'est normal qu'on
se pose des questions mais après vous
savez vous ce qu'il va y avoir au vote
demain soir non pas parce que moi
pendant on est tous au même point mais
c'est parce que les salariés ont réussi
à créer cette tension cette cette
interpellation s'entraide sur le pouvoir
de Monsieur Macron nous en sommes à nous
demander ce qui va se passer s'il
n'avait rien fait il ne se passerait
rien et il y aurait aucune incertitude
je pense qu'ils ont déjà la prime pour
leur courage
tu passes un mot qui terminait ma phrase
ça voulait dire la grève etc alors j'ai
vu avec satisfaction que du coup vous
avez repris ma phrase ça m'a fait
plaisir enfin c'est une règle de la
communication aujourd'hui il faut
exagérer pardon
ça veut dire que il y aura la grève la
continuation de l'action et puis des tas
de choses vous savez ici c'est la France
c'est pas un pays paisible donc vous
pouvez avoir par exemple tout d'un coup
des gens dans une ville qui décident de
faire des réunions générales des
travailleurs une réunion
interprofessionnelle bon ça moi qui vais
le décider mais eux ils peuvent le
décider et alors vous auriez des
rebondissements imprévus il y a dix
jours vous prévoyez pas que les
poubelles allaient se mettre engrais
partout et pourtant ça a lieu donc il
faut accepter que la vie des mouvements
d'une société n'est pas tout n'est pas
prévisible et que l'intervention des
êtres humains heureusement joue en grand
rôle
c'est dans la rue aujourd'hui
mais la loi n'est pas voûtée madame non
mais je sais bien que le Figaro espère
que oui mais c'est même pas sûr parce
que je trouve que dans la droite il y a
des gens qui se posent des questions bon
voilà dans les électeurs de droite il y
a des gens pour qui deux années de
travail de plus ça fait beaucoup et qui
se dit dans quel pour vous Madame bon
c'est pénible alors pas pour vous mais
pour d'autres peut-être davantage il
faut qu'on entende ça là vous n'avez
cette lutte elle sort des catégories
traditionnelles de la politique parce
que tout le monde va payer avec son
corps avec sa vie donc ça bouleverse
beaucoup les les trames et les
répartitions habituelles peut-être que
spontanément quelqu'un de droite dirait
ah bah tous ces ouvriers avec la CGT il
commence à nous saouler et puis après
ben il se dit bah oui mais faire deux
ans de plus et moi que ça saoule bon
voilà
je suis dans la rue aujourd'hui madame
Hidalgo elle a suspendu une partie des
travaux qui étaient prévus au Conseil de
Paris elle vient pas aujourd'hui ça
manque quand on sait quoi j'en pense
rien j'étais pas au courant vous
m'informer il vaut mieux qui est le plus
de monde possible mais bon nous on vient
en appui moi je peux pas vous dire autre
chose ici c'est pas ni la nupestre ni
les insoumis qui ont organisé cette
action donc on vient en appui on se met
à notre place on fait notre travail on
monte on est là eux ils ont monté une
formidable et les parlementaires
insoumis ont monté une caisse de grève
au début on se demandait tous hein parce
que ça allait donner c'est une très
belle réussite chaque fois qu'on arrive
quelque part les gens sont contents de
nous voir je pense qu'on tient bien
notre place au Parlement et dans la rue
suspendu
trouver un spécialiste de l'hidalgo mais
peut-être pas moi je n'y connais rien je
sais pas ce qu'elle fait et j'ose vous
dire que ça m'intéresse pas toujours
beaucoup mais je voulais pas dire une
méchanceté pour terminer
si le gouvernement fait quoi
[Musique]
je réserve mon commentaire au moment il
le fera mais je peux quand même pour
exciter votre curiosité et le suspense
dire que ça serait sûrement pas une
réussite pour lui d'accord parce que je
vous rappelle que après ce qui va se
passer ici quel que soit le vote il y a
encore normalement dans la Constitution
les délais du Conseil const personnel
donc n'allez pas croire que tout ça
d'une quelconque manière réglée
j'imagine que quand nous aurons battu la
droite dans l'assemblée le les
macronistes peut-être que même franc
recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel pour dire ah bah non
c'est pas un bon vote enfin j'en sais
rien je suis comme vous j'en sais pas
plus je sais juste que
c'est eux qui ont la patate chaude c'est
pas nous
bien sûr bon j'en ai tellement vu dans
l'histoire de ce pays où l'on disait oh
là là tout est réglé c'est fini et tout
et puis quick c'est le contraire qui se
passait rappelez-vous comment Monsieur
Chirac a fini par emballer son histoire
on comprenait plus rien la loi a été
promulguée mais elle était retirée ceci
cela enfin bon à la fête il y a pas une
loi quoi non il faut c'est le prof si
vous voulez je comprends qu'on veuille
toujours anticiper mais le là ce qui est
fascinant dans ce que nous vivons c'est
que c'est un moment inouïe dans
l'histoire sociale française vous l'avez
dit vous-même surtout vos médias ça fait
50 ans qu'il y a pas eu de mobilisation
d'une intensité pareille donc bah
regardons cette histoire de notre pays
qui est en train de se faire et on tâche
d'y participer nous chacun choisit son
camp nous on a choisi notre
j'ai toute la vie
aujourd'hui
Mélenchon qui s'exprimait depuis Paris
il n'était pas à Marseille il a répondu
aux questions de Sophie davinel on l'a
entendu la journaliste du service
politique du figure au qui sera sur ce
plateau tout à l'heure je vous le
certifie mon cher Thomas on parlait des
syndicats la CGT voudra aller plus loin
la CFDT
s'arrêterait s'il y avait votes
l'intersyndical est-elle en train
d'exploser alors il y a plusieurs choses
en fait effectivement la question de
l'Inter syndical est-ce que on sent que
l'unité parfaite que l'on a vu pendant
les premières semaines alors elle est
toujours solide je pense mais elle
devient quand même par rapport à mon
plus fragile mais surtout une des choses
qui l'attaquent c'est que vous avez
parlé de la CGT il y a la CGT confédéral
et il y a les différentes fédérations de
la CGT et c'est pas du tout la même
chose les on l'a déjà vu ça a déjà
commencé depuis une à deux semaines
certaines fédérations ont pris des
initiatives sans forcément rendre compte
à la Confédération de durcir le
mouvement voilà sans tenir sans prendre
en compte l'Inter syndical et tout ça
faut pas oublier que effectivement les
syndicats en partie à la CGT les
branches il y a certainement qui sont
souvent très puissantes avec beaucoup
d'autonomie
c'est vrai naturellement et c'est très
très vrai actuellement pour la CGT parce
que je voulais terminer là-dessus parce
que dans 15 jours il y a un congrès et
Martinez plus le secret
et là il y a un vrai duel alors entre
Marie buisson c'est celle qui semble
favorite et qui est poussé par Philippe
Martinez et Olivier matheux alors son
nom ou un autre mais Olivier matheux
c'est un CGTiste des Bouches-du-Rhône
c'est cela très dur il y a eu des mots
parfois tendancieux il est proboutine on
peut le dire ou en tout cas pas
anti-putti noir
il a fait l'apologie du stalinisme il y
a encore récemment sur une chaîne de
télé enfin bon très particulier Olivier
batte oui oui tout à fait donc c'est
vrai que vous l'avez bien noté il y a le
Congrès qui arrive qui sera du 27 au 31
donc peut-être que là on vient
d'assister au dernier carré de tête avec
Philippe Martinez secrétaire général de
la CGT ce qui serait quand même
un combat avec des associations pourrait
être prof un certain pan de la CGT sont
assez proches des milieux écolos mais
d'autres effectivement comme l'industrie
le pétrole qui sont des fédérations très
puissantes à la CGT vous imaginez bien
que ça transpire pas la décroissance et
l'émission 0 carbone des lignes
réconciliables la CGT donc effectivement
Marie buisson serait plus la
représentante de ce mouvement sociétal
là où il est Mathieu qui lui vient des
Bouches-du-Rhône et de l'énergie serait
au contraire celui de la ligne voilà
c'est ça c'est ça donc en fait on peut
s'imaginer que et soit il y a il va y
avoir une lutte assez forte dans ces
enfin qui est déjà présente ce qu'il
faut avoir lieu dans les prochains jours
prochaines semaines pour faire gagner
l'un ou l'autre ou alors les différents
membres les têtes pensantes arriveront à
se réunir à se mettre d'accord et à
faire émerger un compromis un nom et
déjà sorti c'est l'université
de du milieu pénitentiaire elle a
l'avantage de faire partie du bureau
confédéral aujourd'hui donc avec entre
Philippe Martinez et en même temps
d'avoir une ligne un peu plus
vindicative on dirait donc ça pourrait
être un peu voilà le compromis entre les
différents courants peut-être mais pas
de fin des blocages je pense notamment
aux poubelles par exemple là c'est la
l'action la plus visible du moment
est-ce que cela pourrait continuer que
veulent les syndicats
et encore une fois et que veulent les
syndicats officiellement c'est très
simple le retrait de la réforme
officiellement que veulent faire les
syndicats dans les jours qui viennent et
les semaines qui viennent que prévoit-il
j'imagine qu'ils ont un plan ils savent
que demain il y a une très grande chance
que que cette réforme soit votée ou en
tout cas soit adoptée par un 49-3 ils
ont bien un plan ces gens alors je pense
qu'en fait ils vont se laisser une sorte
de porte de sortie ce soir il y a une
inter syndicale
il y aura sûrement pas de grosses
habituellement ils vont dire que la
mobilisation a été forte et que le
gouvernement a été sourd bon peut
sûrement pas d'annonces très importantes
ce soir en revanche et ton déjà prévu de
se réunir dans les jours qui viennent
une fois je pense qu'ils auront la
réponse du 49-3 ou pas donc demain
exactement donc dans les jours après
demain et en fonction je pense que ils
adapteront leur réponse en fonction 49
tro pas et en fonction de ce que ça crée
dans l'opinion publique merci beaucoup
Thomas on va aller sur le terrain je
vous relâche évidemment mais s'il y a
une nouvelle manifestation vous serez là
et oui
bien obligé Mathis le reste sur le
terrain avec une manifestante me
semble-t-il est-ce que le le convoi et
s'est élancé il me semble que oui déjà
Mathis
[Musique]
alors oui Thibault le convoi justement
est en train de s'élancer là je sais pas
si vous voyez sur les images de François
Carpentier et effectivement alors je
suis avec Alice Coulon qui est délégué
syndical de la centrale de de l'une sac
nave est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
pourquoi vous êtes venus manifester
aujourd'hui encore une fois on est venu
à manifester pour contre la réforme des
retraites puisque en tant que salarié de
la sécurité sociale on est doublement
impacté sur ce sur ce sujet en tant que
salarié parce qu'on est en manque
d'effectif et on ne sera pas en capacité
de faire les dossiers de retraite ou de
suivre les mesures de cette réforme et
on n'aura pas on n'aura pas les
capacités ni les effectifs ni les moyens
pour pour faire le nécessaire et puis en
tant qu'assurer puisque à la CNAV il y a
70% de population féminine et on sait
très bien qu'avec cette réforme les les
femmes sont pénalisées
vous personnellement est-ce que vous
avez fait le calcul est-ce que vous
savez
comment elle va vous impacter
de parler trimestre enfant ou
en tant que femme quand on a des enfants
on va être doublement pénalisé puisque
on aura on aura plus de temps de
retraite afin d'annuler à faire et puis
et puis bah après nous on traite de
sujets comme comme la retraite les
dossiers retraites et effectivement on
n'est pas enfin en tant que salarié on
n'est pas on peut pas suivre cette
mesure pour une mise en oeuvre en
septembre 2023 si elle passe en espérant
qu'elle passe pas mais si elle passe de
toute façon
la mise en oeuvre en septembre 2023
c'est c'est utopique de
justement le samedi dernier il y avait
beaucoup de moins de monde aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être la dernière
manifestation avant impossible vote
est-ce que vous avez encore un espoir on
a un espoir parce que même enfin les les
votes sont incertains avec la commission
paritaire qui se qui se déroulent en ce
moment et et comment dire sur le 49-3
s'il y a un 49,3 bah là ça remettra la
machine en route on espère au niveau des
salariés et de les des citoyens français
parce que encore enfin un nouveau 49-3
ça serait ça serait une double peine et
pour pour les citoyens et pour pour le
gouvernement qui sera totalement mise en
désaccord donc s'il y a encore 9 3 à
l'une sachenave vous descendez dans la
rue quoi qu'il arrive pas dans la rue et
on sera à
jusqu'au boutiste sur cette réforme des
retraites ça c'est sûr merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup pour le prise de parole
voilà Thibault je vous repasse la parole
[Musique]
avec des gens qu'on entend bien derrière
dans la manifestation François de
lettrage comment ça va très bien bon
spécialiste des transports au bagazine
évidemment c'était comment ce matin un
peu le bazar dans les transports où ça
allait alors le meilleur indicateur pour
savoir comment ça se passe sans les
transports c'est de regarder les
bouchons oui ah oui très intéressant et
donc les bouchons ce matin ça a été le
tsunami on a eu 430 km de bouchon
cumulés à 8h du matin cette petite
courbe alors je vais je vais la montrer
on peut la montrer à nos internautes je
vais demander à Riad Becker de quitter
un instant voilà on voit donc c'était
quand ici ici voilà à 8h du matin vous
voyez c'est ça c'est aujourd'hui le
rouge quand c'est exceptionnel
et le jaune avec la ligne bleue au
milieu c'est la normale donc vous voyez
que par rapport à la normale on était
quasiment au double de bouchon de la
normale d'accord donc beaucoup de
bouchons cela veut dire que les
transports en commun étaient bloqués ce
matin donc les gens prennent la voiture
ça veut dire que les gens avaient non ça
veut dire que les gens un ne pouvaient
plus faire tous du télétravail ils
avaient plus plus de RTT et que ils
avaient peur des transports en commun
donc ils ont pris leur voiture pour être
sûr de pouvoir arriver bon ça donne quoi
la SNCF à la à la RATP
en région parisienne
quelques grosses lignes qui sont
toujours très très impactés oui en
particulier le RER A et le RER B
d'accord vous savez que le RER A ça
transporte un million de personnes par
jour et là il y a intra sur deux en ce
moment oui d'accord donc c'est colossal
sur le plan du métro
salé un petit peu mieux ce matin il y
avait une ou deux lignes qui étaient
très impactée mais il y en avait quand
même une dizaine qui roulait normalement
donc c'était très différent et sur le
Transilien donc les trains de banlieue
la ligne la plus importée c'est la ligne
D qui est une énorme ligne et surtout la
ligne D il y avait plus d'interconnexion
à la au Châtelet et à la gare de Lyon
donc il y avait plus de train entre ces
deux gares d'accord donc les gens
étaient obligés de descendre du train
Châtelet prendre le RER A alors qu'il y
en a qu'un sur deux aller jusqu'à la
gare de Lyon et à la gare il y a une
automatique
par jour et elle est déjà totalement
saturée je comprends je comprends ce que
vous me dites moi alors SNCF RATP
qu'ils ont fait vraiment la grève au
point auquel on pouvait l'attendre j'ai
l'impression qu'il des gens n'ont pas
été si perturbés que ça aussi depuis
deux mois quand même les travaux ont été
très très perturbés alors on attendait
des blocages la semaine dernière la RATP
a du non bah finalement nous on va pas
se mettre en grève
ils ont quand même arrêté la moitié des
lignes il y avait il y avait 40 stations
de fermer il y avait il y a des stations
qui ont marché que de 8h à 10h et de 16h
à 17h enfin bon ça a été quand même
colossal et en région aussi donc mais en
revanche ce qui se passe depuis quelques
jours c'est qu'on est sur un palier qui
reste le même et on s'attendait
aujourd'hui à cause des manifestations à
ce qui est un accroissement du nombre de
grévistes et ça a pas été le cas je vous
savez qu'on a ce qu'on appelle le
d2i
déclarations individuelles d'intention
si on déclare être et donc un certain
nombre de professions qui sont obligés
de se déclarer pour le premier jour de
grève il faut qu'il se déclare 48 heures
à l'avance ou quand la grève est
reconduite il se déclare 24 heures à
l'avance et hier il y a pas eu un pic de
déclaration de grévistes pour
aujourd'hui
dans un instant continue à parler des
transports mais d'abord on va sur le
terrain on va retrouver Damien Canivez
Damien qui est devant les les barricades
me semble-t-il parce qu'il faut que
cette manifestation suive son axe on ne
veut surtout pas que ça déborde c'est
bien ça et notamment on ne veut pas que
cette manifestation se retrouve devant
l'Assemblée nationale si j'ai bien
compris
mais vous avez parfaitement compris Tibo
effectivement je me trouve actuellement
place des Invalides à l'endroit où la
manifestation doit s'élancer et
rejoindre la place d'Italie mais je me
trouve plus particulièrement et vous
l'avez bien noté à l'entrée du pont
Alexandre 3 où se trouve effectivement
juste derrière moi cette véhicule de
gendarmerie voilà qui sont prêts à
débouler à tout moment avec un canon à
eau de la Compagnie républicaine de
sécurité alors pourquoi se trouve-t-il
ici et bien tout simplement parce que le
pont Alexandre 3 traverse la Seine et
peut mener directement à l'Assemblée
nationale qui se trouve à quelques
dizaines de mètres de la place des
Invalides c'est là-bas qu'actuellement
se rencontrent 7 députés et sept
sénateurs en commission mixte paritaire
afin d'établir un texte commun qui ira
demain au Sénat demain matin au Sénat et
puis l'après-midi à l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez remarqué le
dispositif policier est assez
impressionnant derrière moi dépassant
trier évidemment et fouillant l'imagine
de l'autre côté peuvent passer et
rejoindre la manifestation du Pont
Alexandre 3 vers les invalides mais les
Invalides vers l'Assemblée nationale
c'est évidemment interdit d'y aller pour
le moment le dispositif policier sur la
manifestation et assez important au
total 23 compagnie de CRS ont été
mobilisés ce qui représente à peu près
1800 hommes 24 compagnies de gendarmerie
mobile également sont ici pour sécuriser
le cortège cette fois-ci c'est 1700
hommes vous faites le calcul
effectivement c'est un dispositif
policier assez important pour le moment
la place des Invalides est loin d'être
pleine il faut dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont en tout cas elle est en
train de se remplir et vous pouvez le
voir sur les images de Julien Leclerc
qui est en train de cadrer cette place
que c'est assez clairsemé mais que c'est
en train de se remplir tout doucement
merci beaucoup Damien Canivez oui ce
point Alexandre 3 qui mène vers l'Elysée
surtout et voilà c'est sur cette route
là qu'on peut se diriger vers
l'Assemblée nationale évidemment bon
quelle est la suite du programme à la
RATP et la SNCF ce qu'on a déjà
anticipé ce qui pouvait se passer demain
non pas de faire une analyse politique
François de lettrage vous demande de me
dire est-ce que les grèves vont
s'arrêter dans les transports en commun
demain après-demain et les semaines qui
viennent alors pour demain c'est trop
tôt pour vous le dire parce que la
déclaration est doit être faite
aujourd'hui et on aura les comptes
rendus de la RATP de la SNCF à 17h il
prévoit que ce sera à peu près similaire
à aujourd'hui et ce jusqu'à la fin du
week-end et on prévoit une amélioration
à partir du week-end sauf si ça se
passait vraiment mal à l'Assemblée bon
nous verrons mais bon ce qui est
important ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
dans les transports
pourquoi est-ce que on a un train sur
deux pourquoi est-ce que alors qu'il y a
des gens qui travaillent oui parce qu'il
suffit qu'il y ait
un aiguilleur c'est comme les
aiguilleurs du ciel il suffit qu'on est
quelqu'un à un aiguillage le métier
charnière qui est pas là et le train
peut pas passer il suffit que il manque
un conducteur pour que le même s'il
contrôleur est là pour que le train
puisse pas partir et inversement il
suffit il faut obligatoirement
incontrôleur par rame et donc si le
contrôlerait pas là le train peut pas
partir que le taux de grévise n'est pas
si élevé que ça à la RATP
il est assez élevé mais à la RATP par
exemple ils ont réussi à compenser
énormément les grévistes parce que tous
les cadres de maîtrise et les cadres se
sont mis à faire rouler des trains donc
ils ont compensé un petit peu
l'encadrement qui roule qui roule
aujourd'hui et depuis une semaine
comment ça s'est passé ces dernières
semaines on parlait d'un mouvement plus
dur durable ça pas vraiment pris ici ça
a pris au début la première journée a
été phénoménale et puis ça s'est un peu
larvé depuis et du mois de janvier c'est
ça
la semaine dernière mais c'est à dire
que la SNCF qui a un pouvoir de nuisance
puisque les transports on le sait sont
impactant pour les Français
là ils ont pas réussi complètement à
tenir une semaine deux semaines trois
semaines
mais bon ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'elle a SNCF il y a deux il y a deux
tranches il y a les transports du
quotidien et les grandes lignes les
grandes en comparaison du transport du
quotidien ça transporte très peu de
monde ah bon oui d'accord les TGV
transportent très peu de monde par
rapport aux petits
les TER et et transigné en Île-de-France
et le RER c'est des millions de
personnes tous les jours alors quand TGV
c'est des dizaines de milliers donc
voyez on n'est pas du tout dans le même
dans le même rapport de nuisances qui
peut y avoir donc là le fait d'avoir un
TER sur deux en région en ce moment ça
c'est très impactant pour la vie
quotidienne des gens ces images en
direct de Paris le cortège vient de
s'élancer on voit les leaders syndicaux
en aperçoit Frédéric Marty Philippe
Martinez évidemment à gauche et Frédéric
Souillot juste à côté de lui de Force
Ouvrière Laurent Berger tac on l'a perçu
juste à gauche ce France syndical qui
reste uni pour l'instant allez-y
François sur le c'est assez important
pour une fois c'est pas les syndicats
juste aboutissent qui font grève et bah
il y a à la fois les syndicats
réformistes une SAS et FDT et la CGT est
Sudra dans les transports qui font grève
et alors la CFDT est plus faible dans
les transports ça dépend des endroits
leadership au niveau national exactement
mais quelqu'un qui est très très fort à
la RATP par exemple c'est l'une ça oui
alors que c'est un syndicat réformiste
sauf que la branche UNSA de la RATP est
un peu plus dur que ne l'une ça sur le
plan national mais il n'empêche que
c'est quand même très rare qu'on est
toutes les fédérations syndicales en
même temps qui demande à faire appel
grève
qui appelle à faire la grève bien sûr
quelle est la réaction du du
gouvernement de Clément Beaune notamment
qui est ministre du Transport
je ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez
François peut-être que c'est qu'un avis
c'est grève des transports qui
d'habitude font en parler d'elle cette
fois et bien ce n'est pas ce qui marque
le plus regardez depuis trois jours on
parle de la grève des poubelles des
éboueurs mais pas forcément des
transports pourtant la grève des
transports a été plus impactante que la
grève des poubelles mais la grève des
poubelles est plus visible en décembre
2019 on parlait que de ça des trains
c'est moins le cas non
sur plan communication c'est moins le
cas le gouvernement a plutôt bien géré
visiblement ça comme pour que
une majorité de français commence à
trouver la réforme peut-être nécessaire
est-ce que les syndicats dont on voit
les leaders ici ont la main sur les
employés du rail il faut pas un peu ce
qu'ils veulent les employés ils ont des
ce sont des fédérations très
indépendantes non alors c'est des
fédérations très indépendantes mais en
fait qui font bloc et qui se qui
s'entendent elles-mêmes l'exemple de
décembre dernier avec les contrôleurs et
quand même assez exceptionnel
à savoir que les contrôleurs ont créé
des groupes WhatsApp et ce sont des ont
décidé de se mettre en grève sans l'avis
de la centrale ce qui était quand même
excès extraordinaire mais ça arrive très
rarement surtout dans des entreprises
aussi syndiquées que celle là oui c'est
ça
de la grève on parle souvent de ça une
culture de la grève dans dans ces
secteurs du transport c'est toujours le
cas et d'où ça vient alors ça vient du
fait que c'était des métiers très durs
autrefois
et donc ça a été des entreprises très
syndiquées dès le départ
les gens défendaient honnêtement quand
vous étiez mal je le dis toujours mais
quand on est machiniste dans un train à
vapeur qu'on manie du charbon etc qu'on
arrive le soir on écrase ceux on a
travaillé d'arrache-pied toute la
journée on a plus de demandes que quand
on est aujourd'hui conducteur de TGV et
donc il y a un ADN dans l'entreprise qui
fait que les métiers étaient très le
contrôleur pour contrôler son train
autrefois il sortait il sortait d'avagon
à l'autre pour par le froid par l'hiver
par le soleil etc etc donc c'était des
métiers qui n'avaient rien à voir et qui
se sont syndiqués très très très haut
parce que contrairement à d'autres
réformes d'autres moments ils sont moins
concernés directement en tout cas on
touche quasiment pas au régime spéciaux
là sur cette réforme alors évidemment et
la clause du grand-père mais c'est à
dire que ces régimes spéciaux
s'arrêteront dans 43 ans quand les
derniers embauchés sous les régimes
spéciaux
donc les nouveaux les nouveaux arrivants
alors chez les nouveaux arrivants il y a
un sentiment mitigé à savoir qu'ils se
disent plus on a la autant
d'inconvénients que les anciens et on
n'a pas les mêmes avantages donc il y a
chez les jeunes une forte
syndicalisation aussi alors qu'on
pensait que avec l'arrivée des nouvelles
générations à la SNCF par exemple il y
aurait une syndicalisation moins forte
c'est pas le cas on va retourner sur le
sur le terrain François on va retrouver
Mathis fleuret Matisse vous êtes au cœur
de la manifestation avec un des invités
peut-être est-ce que vous êtes élancé
vous de l'Esplanade des Invalides
alors oui Thibault alors nous on est
plutôt parti vers la fin du du cortège
là on remonte vers vers la CFDT que vous
voyez derrière moi sur les images de de
François Carpentier alors on a remonté
on a remonté l'esplanade et le cortège
est
un peu long mais c'est un peu clairsemé
tout de même on va pas vous cacher mais
on va essayer de vous trouver de vous
trouver des manifestants qui veulent
bien qui veulent bien nous répondre
mon cher Thibault et on voit on
reviendra vers vous tout de suite
merci Mathis merci oui c'est vrai que
faire semer c'est peut-être normal aussi
l'esplanade des Invalides c'est très
grand pour lancer une manifestation que
vous voyez ce cortège qui vient vous
savez c'est comme dans un spectacle vous
avez intérêt à avoir une petite salle
pleine plutôt qu'une grande salle vide
oui c'est ça
il y a un mauvais choix ils sont fait
piéger par la préfecture de police qui
leur a conseillé de partir des Invalides
bon
est-ce que c'est manifestations
n'ont pas été directement insufflé par
les syndicats de transports qui sont
souvent
en première ligne qui donne le la le
taux les syndicats d'enseignants aussi
vous avez raison de le préciser c'est
important
ne se sont pas impliqués plus
directement vous qui connaissez
particulièrement la question des
transports pourquoi nous n'y sont pas
allés plus directement plutôt dans le
mois de janvier par exemple non mais
quand vous décidez de mobiliser des
troupes c'est comme les auditeurs qui
nous écoutent aujourd'hui on sait pas
combien vont venir oui c'est vrai
pardon pour ce parallèle mais c'est la
même chose pour une manifestation vous
lancez une manifestation alors il y a
évidemment tout le problème de
l'organisation des autobus des
fédérations etc qui organise tout ça
mais ça coûte beaucoup d'argent et puis
après ça il y a la le volontariat qui
fait qu'il y a beaucoup de monde ou pas
beaucoup de monde
évidemment et là il fait beau
aujourd'hui il pleut pas il aurait pu y
avoir plus de monde oui c'est vrai on va
aller un petit peu dans la manifestation
on va écouter ce qu'il se dit on va
s'imprégner de cette manifestation à un
instant avec ces images de la tête du
cortège on aperçoit quelques leaders
syndicaux en écoute ce qu'il se dit
[Musique]
un drapeau
trivago à gauche
[Musique]
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
EDF GDF 100% public tiens intéressant ça
franchement moi je trouve ça formidable
que j'aime c'est d'abord la
manifestation c'est une chose très
française
et en Allemagne en Italie en Espagne
beaucoup moins tous les tous les
étrangers qui viennent ici disent
toujours mais il y a quoi comme
manifestation aujourd'hui à savoir qu'on
est quand même
clichés du genre et puis deuxième chose
regardez ce qu'on a vu sur EDF GDF ici
sont mis quand même à plusieurs ils y
ont travaillé pendant plusieurs jours où
ils ont fait leur drapeau ils viennent
le déployer aux Invalides etc il y a un
esprit de corps qui est quand même
étonnant oui c'est vrai vous avez raison
de le dire tiens on va voir l'esprit de
corps on va essayer de le retrouver dans
la manifestation peut-être parce que
Damien Canivez ce qui a fait plusieurs
manifestations on va pouvoir nous dire
si il y a du monde aujourd'hui Damien
vous êtes dans
dans le cortège dites-moi
absolument je suis dans le cortège très
exactement au niveau du groupe Force
Ouvrière on essaie de rejoindre la tête
de cortège actuellement et pour avoir
participé avec vous Thibault la
manifestation qui a eu lieu le 7 mars
dernier on a l'impression qu'il y a
quand même beaucoup moins de monde
aujourd'hui à Paris et c'est sans doute
lié aussi voilà une forme de l'acide de
de d'affaiblissement du mouvement on l'a
pu le voir aussi à travers les chiffres
qui sont sortis à la mi-journée et que
les syndicats ont que la police a pu
communiquer voilà c'était 75000
manifestants à Rennes par exemple
c'était beaucoup 75000 pardon je suis en
train de vous dire des bêtises en
attendant Thibault la grande question
d'aujourd'hui c'est de savoir si il va y
avoir une forme de radicalisation parce
que certes comme je vous le disais les
manifestants sont beaucoup moins
nombreux mais ils sont aussi déterminés
on a vu dans la bouche de certains
leaders syndicaux et des parts syndicaux
pardon et politique une forme de
violence dans certains propos Olivier le
bateau par exemple le patron de la CGT
départemental des Bouches-du-Rhône qui a
dit que c'est le 49-3 allait passer dans
ce cas là il n'y aurait plus de règles
ici les slogans peuvent être aussi assez
virulents et on va essayer d'être
attentif à ça justement aujourd'hui
est-ce que les manifestants sont
déterminés les vraiment jusqu'au retrait
de la réforme même si elle passe à
travers le 49-3 ou bien est-ce qu'il va
y avoir tout simplement un
affaiblissement de la mobilisation comme
on est en train de le voir ici c'est la
grande question et on tentera d'y
répondre aujourd'hui merci Damien canive
merci de nous rendre compte de ce qu'il
se passe dans cette manifestation
d'accueil Bruno Payet bonjour bonjour
directeur de recherche du CNRS au Centre
d'études européennes de Sciences Po qui
auteur de du livre réformer les
retraites aux éditions c'est ça
trouver évidemment ça j'imagine sur
Internet oui tout à fait bon votre
regard sur ce que vous voyez là
aujourd'hui c'est manifestation depuis
deux mois est-ce que est-ce que c'est
une réussite
moi je ne sais pas ce qui réussit ou ce
qui est chaud si je vais pas les
critères
aux déchets le premier critère ça sera
décidé peut-être demain c'est à dire le
retrait d'un projet de réforme 64 ans
mais il n'y a pas que ça il y a d'autres
critères ou d'autres choses qui sont
passées du côté du mouvement social
l'unité syndicale elle est parfaitement
unique dans l'histoire des mobilisations
la prise de parole des manifestants qui
estiment avoir des choses à dire et des
choses à dire sur leurs conditions de
travail sur le travail donc voilà c'est
c'est aussi ça qui se passe avec avec ce
mouvement à quoi ça sert ces mouvements
comme celui-ci lorsque j'envoie le
gouvernement qui chaque soir de
manifestation vient sur les plateaux
télé il dit bravo très belle
manifestation ça c'est bien tenu mais
nous on continue à quoi ça sert de faire
ça ça sert encore quelque chose de
manifester
moi j'ai envie de vous retourner à la
question à quoi ça sert à quoi ça sert
de ne pas tenir compte de ce qui se dit
pendant deux mois un degré de d'opinion
très très élevé
puisque on sait que la politique horreur
du vigne et que si il y a pas d'écoute
là et ça se manifestera autrement allez
vous pensez bien sûr c'est à dire moi je
viens de publier une note pour le cercle
de réflexion Terra Nova dans la grande
conversation et j'y expose qu'il y a
dans cette réforme les ingrédients qui
nourrissent
traditionnellement le vote pour les
parties populistes de droites radicale
en l'occurrence le rassemblement
national je l'ai déjà exposé à Vincent
roux ici il n'y a pas très longtemps et
donc c'est c'est ingrédients c'est
d'abord il ne nous écoute pas c'est un
discours récurrent des partis populistes
nous sommes les seuls à porter la voie
du peuple à porter la voix puisque les
élites nous écoutent pas deuxième
élément qu'on entend souvent dans la
voie des populistes il nous manque voilà
il y a eu un débat pas terrible et puis
plus substantiellement c'est de regarder
qui sont les manifestants et vous le
voyez on a des images qui défilent c'est
des travailleurs des salariés c'est pas
des feignants c'est pas des assistés
c'est pas des cassos comme parfois on
peut l'entendre justement ils disent moi
je travaille je voudrais être reconnu je
voudrais être entendu parce que c'est
dur et ce qu'ils disent de ce qui est
dur c'est je n'arrive plus à faire bien
mon travail si on veut parler
régulièrement c'est à dire vous êtes
bien gentil travailler un peu plus oui
je veux bien être pragmatique comme vous
me demandez on vieillit longtemps vit
plus vieux donc je vais bien travailler
plus longtemps mais pas dans ces
conditions là exactement et donc c'est
vraiment ça les gens disent pas moi je
veux partir le plus vite possible parce
que je suis une grosse feignasse et vive
les vacances dit c'est dans ces
conditions quand même vive les vacances
aussi mais pas pas de travail c'est
vraiment c'est ça qui se dit et
justement c'est pour ça que les
Syndicates représentent ça et du coup
c'est assez intéressant parce que ça de
part et d'autre c'est une réussite de ce
moment je le dis de façon peut-être un
peu progressiste et on parle enfin des
questions essentielles du travail
c'est-à-dire les conditions de travail
c'est à dire la relation au travail et
on entend bien de part et d'autre là de
beaucoup de parlementaires qu'il est
qu'il faut se soucier de cela et c'est
bien ce qui est dit là mais si c'est pas
entendu si c'est pas entendu ce que je
raconte dans cette dans cette note c'est
vraiment qu'on a l'un deux ingrédients
autour du travail qui qui nourrissent
aussi ce type de vote le premier
ingrédient c'est que
les électeurs qui votent le plus pour ce
type de partie c'est les classes
moyennes en déclin c'est des classes
moyennes menacés donc c'est vraiment le
travail donc vous voyez une infirmière
un gilet jaune une chose comme ça et
d'autre part ce qui nourrit le
ressentiment politique qui s'exprime
mais souvent sur le lieu de travail dans
les relations de travail
un doctorant du Centre d'étude
européenne de Sciences Po pour les
Wagner et en fait sa question c'était de
comprendre pourquoi les ouvriers en
Autriche votre île pour le FPE donc et
le parti de droite radical là-bas et
donc il les a interviewé il les a
observé et ce qu'il a étonné son premier
étonnement ça a été de dire mais il ne
me parle que du boulot il me parle du
travail il me parle pas des immigrés il
me parle pas de de barbecue si je peux
danser
très simplement que la cour au bord à
cette grande idée que la gauche a perdu
le va t'ouvrir parce qu'elle ne lui
parle plus du tout à l'ouvrier moi je
pense effectivement que il y a la gauche
il y a aussi peut-être le centre ou la
droite qui est de gouvernement qui avait
peut-être moins ce vote comme acquis qui
a peu oui oui mais si vous voulez
personne n'a su pour l'instant parler du
travail comme ce monsieur ou d'autres
ont envie qu'on parle du travail c'est à
dire c'est quoi mes conditions comment
je suis traité par mon chef est-ce que
disent beaucoup les gens je suis traité
comme un numéro on tient pas compte de
mon avis et pourtant j'ai une expertise
et pourtant j'ai des compétences il y a
plus de collectifs de travail et ça
c'est pas de gauche c'est pas de droite
en fait c'est qu'il faut en parler
on va parler de la suite parce que les
conséquences de cette séquence
et bien
je ne sais que je sais que vous n'êtes
pas prophète et que vous n'avez pas une
boule de cristal mais vous pouvez les
imaginer tout à fait en tout cas on
imaginait les syndicats morts on disait
ça il y a quelques années lors des
gilets jaunes là de ce point de vue là
c'est une réussite eux ils ont réussi à
amener les gens dans la rue
contrairement à d'autres on pense à
certaines manifestations politiques
notamment menées par Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui ont fait qui ont eu beaucoup moins
de succès il y a deux raisons à cela
d'abord les syndicats sont les
représentants naturels des travailleurs
et c'est un conflit autour du travail
c'est pas un conflit autour de la
réforme des retraites parce qu'il y a
pas quelque part c'est pas une réforme
des retraites on changerait au système
de retraite c'est une réforme qui dit il
faut travailler plus longtemps donc les
syndicats représentent les travailleurs
qui disent je ne veux pas travailler
plus longtemps dans ces conditions comme
vous l'avez parfaitement formulé la
deuxième chose c'est que ça n'est pas du
tout exceptionnel sur les questions de
protection sociale et en particulier de
retraite les syndicats ont toujours été
perçues comme les représentants
légitimes de ces questions là donc il y
a toujours eu des manifestations
1993 mais toutes les autres réformes
merveilles il y a toujours une
immobilisation par les syndicats c'est
perdu comme légitime ça tient la nature
de notre système de protection sociale
il est hérité vous le savez de
l'après-guerre et c'est ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque la démocratie
sociale c'était les partenaires sociaux
les employeurs et les salariés qui
gérait ensemble le système ça c'est un
peu délité
de passer par ces organisations elle
permet d'air mais ce certain Emmanuel
Macron il a eu un prédécesseur et ce
prédécesseur a reconnu son erreur
Alain Juppé il a fait un plan de réforme
parce que Alain Juppé son erreur et là
c'est pas moi qui juge même qu'il a dit
c'est de croire que l'État pouvait
réformer la sécurité sociale sans en
discuter avec les partenaires sociaux si
vous vous rappelez du plan Juppé c'est
décidé à dire aux fonctionnaires dans
les sous-sols de Matignon c'est secret
c'est lâcher comme ça et bien il avait
pas compris la nature du système où les
représentants légitimes de la protection
sociale ce sont ceux qui payent
c'est-à-dire les employeurs les
cotisations sociales et les salariés
alors ça c'est d'éviter encore une fois
parce qu'il y a une étatisation de la
sécurité sociale c'était beaucoup plus
budget voté par les décisions mais on
garde des traces à l'agirco les
retraites complémentaires on garde des
traces ici là dans ce qui se passe là du
fait que c'est issu du monde du travail
pour les travailleurs gérés par les
représentants des employeurs et des
travailleurs continuer à discuter mais
d'abord je voudrais qu'on aille sur le
terrain on a deux équipes sur le terrain
ils ont tous les deux ils sont tous les
deux avec des manifestants on commence
par Damien Canivez Damien deux petites
questions et après on ira voir Mathis
fleuret vous êtes avec un pompier vous
Damien
oui
alors non malgré les apparences je suis
avec Nicolas qui est responsable de la
coordination du syndicat Île-de-France
FNME CGT bonjour Nicolas alors vous êtes
ici dans la manifestation manifestement
vous ne manifestez pas uniquement contre
la réforme des retraites vous êtes aussi
pour la nationalisation de DF c'est un
peu le slogan qui qu'on peut entendre
derrière ouais tout à fait on est pour
la nationalisation mais pas la
nationalisation à la sauce Macron on est
pour la réalisation c'est-à-dire que les
entreprises historiques redeviennent des
epics pas étatisés comme ils sont en
train de le faire aujourd'hui
en revendant les parts mais en laissant
le marché de l'électricité sur bah sur
le marché de la Bourse en fait doit pas
spéculer avec l'énergie alors dernière
question que je voulais vous poser aussi
c'est que vous vous travaillez dans le
secteur de l'énergie forcément vous êtes
touché par les la fin des régimes
spéciaux c'est vraiment ça qui vous
embête dans cette réforme ah bah notre
régime c'est un régime pionnier c'est ce
qui nous permet avec la pénibilité de
pouvoir partir plus tôt parce que je
vous assure que des collègues qui
travaillent toute la journée à monter au
poteau à descendre dans les à travailler
auprès du feu etc c'est des vrais des
vrais critères de pénibilité et ça on
peut pas laisser faire on peut pas
laisser passer comme ça un mec qui
devait partir à 57 ans devra partir à 59
et il sera encore plus cassé que quand
il part la plupart des mecs ils sont
cassés à 45 ans on veut quoi en fait on
veut qu'on meurt au travail juste une
toute dernière question peut-être que la
réforme demain va passer à l'aide du
49-3 si tel est le cas jusqu'où
êtes-vous prêt à aller jusqu'au bout
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire par là ah
bah vous avez pu voir des petits
exemples qui sont passés un peu partout
en France de la sobriété énergétique ils
vont la connaître de encore plus
massivement c'est à dire des coupures
d'électricité pour des élus des
personnes qui se trouvent dans des
instances pour les élus mais pour on va
couper l'électricité ouais bah merci
beaucoup Nicolas pour pour votre
témoignage
merci d'Amiens caniveys euh j'ai promis
qu'on irait ensuite avec Mathis fleur et
Matisse aussi vous êtes avec un un
militant vous avez la parole
alors attendez on se décale hop juste un
petit peu pour avoir quand même un plus
joli cadre voilà alors je suis avec
Fabien Villedieu qui est porte-parole de
de SUD Rail
il y avait beaucoup moins de monde
samedi dernier est-ce que vous y croyez
encore vous aujourd'hui retrait de cette
réforme bah écoutez on est dans un
processus long qui a commencé le 19
janvier voilà avec des manifestations
historiques y compris qu'on avait pas vu
même lorsqu'on prend les chiffres de la
police depuis ces 30 ou 40 dernières
années voilà donc et là on est un peu
vers le bout voilà la fin l'arrivée qui
va gagner ça j'en sais rien mais c'est
pas un moment où on arrive à l'arrivée
qu'il faut s'arrêter voilà donc moi quel
que soit le chiffre de mobilisation même
si c'est un succès un demi succès la
moitié d'un succès le carnet succès à la
limite je m'en fous voilà là ça
il y a la commission mixparitaire
aujourd'hui ça va demain ça n'a aucun
sens de pas se mobiliser aujourd'hui et
demain
devant la ligne d'arriver s'arrêter dans
une course de fond ça serait
complètement stupide donc d'où on va
aller jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout ça
veut dire un minimum jusqu'à demain
parce qu'on pense que le rapport de
force on doit mettre la pression
effectivement au parlementaire et pour
mettre la pression parlementaire mais
c'est en manifestation c'est être
gréviste voilà nous on y croit on y
croit encore peut-être que certains sont
fatalistes mais moi je vous dis les
enjeux sont trop importants on n'a pas
le droit au fatalisme les enjeux sont
trop importants les enjeux c'est quoi
c'est nous voler deux meilleures années
de retraite et les remplacer par les
deux pires années de travail et ben on
regarde ça même si c'est dur même si des
fois on aimerait qu'il y ait plus de
grévistes même si des fois on aimerait
qu'il y ait plus de manifestants et ben
on serre les dents et on continue
[Musique]
la dernière manif avant que le texte ne
soit beauté justement est-ce que vous
vous arrêtez vous vous arrêtez là
il y aura demain pourquoi les le pin
c'est pas embrasé pourquoi ce fameux
blocage réclamé par certains notamment
la semaine dernière les syndicats n'ont
pas été en capacité de les mener à bout
est-ce qu'on peut pas dire c'est parce
que les syndicats ont fait le pari de la
modération oui mais ce qui est dans la
nature même de contraint d'unité de
l'intersydicale ils ont fait le pari de
la modération donc surtout et avant tout
des mobilisations
et ils ont pas joué là on a entendu deux
fois jusqu'au bout ils ont justement pas
joué jusqu'au-boutisme c'est très clair
dans il y a pas que Laurent Berger
que les autres et puis la deuxième chose
c'est que c'est pas évident de faire une
live en période d'inflation et 14% sur
les produits alimentaires vous faites
vos calculs ça se voit très très vite ça
a commencé en janvier donc vous avez la
feuille de paye de fin janvier qui le
montre donc il y a ces deux raisons là
qui sont effectivement
une sorte de d'anomalie par rapport à la
à la comment dire la hauteur des
affirmations de l'opinion publique
c'est-à-dire que sur un enjeu de réforme
des retraites vous avez eu dans le passé
des sondages qui étaient plutôt contre
la réforme mais avec une telle ampleur
un tel niveau donc vous savez c'est
entre 63 et 70%. et avec une telle
stabilité dans le temps c'est vrai qu'on
peut se dire c'est bizarre que le pays
ne soit pas embrasé et je dirais que les
gens qui sont contre bon ils sont contre
mais si la réforme passe à de mes
empêchera pas de dormir
c'est ce que j'essayais d'écrire dans
cette note dont on parle c'est que le
de résignation le suivant s'est
ressentiment c'est clair c'est que vous
avez l'idée moi je travaille vous pouvez
pas me reprocher de pas être un
travailleur j'essaye de vous expliquer
pourquoi dans ces conditions je veux pas
travailler plus longtemps vous ne
m'écoutez pas certes peut-être que je
suis résigné au sens où ça va passer
mais la chose ne va pas s'évaporer ce
sentiment c'est à dire que donc il va y
avoir des métamorphoses après des traces
vont rester là dans la dans l'opinion
publique mais les gens ils vont pas
rentrer chez eux et puis retourner
travailler et la vie continue mais il va
y avoir ils vont faire la tête
et moi c'est vraiment mon argument c'est
que ça va couver donc comme des braises
et puis le moment où alors soit ça peut
s'enflammer plus tard le risque il est
évidemment que ça s'enflamme sous une
forme beaucoup plus embrasée pour
reprendre votre mot parce que la
modération ça passe pas ça marche pas
donc passer à autre chose
ce type de choses
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que quand on
demandera leur avis aux Français on va
leur demander à l'occasion des élections
européennes des élections dans deux ans
voilà et des élections présidentielles
là ils auront des choses à dire et
l'objectif de mon analyse politique elle
est de montrer que ce type de choses
c'est-à-dire cet événement le vécu là le
ressentiment il peut durer pendant trois
quatre ans et ressortir après on a pu le
voir dans le passé je parlais d'Alain
Juppé tout à l'heure entre 95 et 97 il y
a un lien assez direct qui a été
démontré par la science politique entre
2011 la réforme Fornero en Italie et
l'arrivée de des partis populistes en
2018 il y a un lien sur la réforme des
retraites ça a été ça a été montré voilà
ça laisse des marques ça laisse des
traces c'est ce que vous avez dit là
alors après c'est aux acteurs politiques
des différents partis de de réinvestir
cette trace de pas croire ouf on est
passé ça va passer à autre chose il y a
un sentiment donc c'est à chacun des
acteurs de cette réforme politique donc
les LR comme comme les autres de de
savoir donner un écho à ce qui a essayé
de se dire ici toujours difficile à dire
mais politiquement qui qui sort qui
semble sortir renforcé de cette séquence
vous me dites depuis tout à l'heure que
c'est plutôt une Marine Le Pen qui en
profiterait pourquoi pas la gauche
pourquoi pas la gauche d'abord parce que
l'État
institutionnel
si on considère que c'est à peu près 30%
des deux côtés pas tout à fait vous avez
un une leader un parti quasiment
je sais pas bien compter j'en ai vu un
leader quand même Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pas les 30%, vous voyez donc il a réussi
à le faire pour la nude ouais mais voilà
est-ce que on peut repasser les plats
vous avez vu la division donc ça c'est
la chose mais la deuxième chose c'est
que pour l'instant on le disait tout à
l'heure c'est vous qui le rappeliez il y
a un certain nombre de parties de gauche
qui ont du mal à savoir parler au
travail du travail des travailleurs donc
alors que le rassemblement national
c'est ce que j'essaie d'expliquer aussi
dans cette note il a une façon de le
faire et la façon de le faire c'est
d'opposer ces classes moyennes menacées
qui travaillent avec la caricature
qu'ils font des assistés je pense que
c'est une caricature vous vous
travaillez eux ils foutent rien et vous
payez pour eux et vous on s'occupe pas
de vous et ce que je souligne c'est que
le schéma de la réforme des retraites se
prête à ce type d'interprétation les
gens qui travaillent et qui vont devoir
travailler plus longtemps sans filtre
sans compensation c'est ces classes
moyennes menacés une question qui me
vient vraiment de ne pas l'aimer lorsque
je vois tous ces ballons essayer de
drapeaux Force Ouvrière c'est jeté les
autres sont des syndicats classés à
gauche
est-ce que tous ces électeurs de Marine
Le Pen qui représentent presque 40%
deuxième tour de la présidentielle et
qui
le Parlement l'Assemblée nationale ne
servait à rien nombre blocage notamment
pendant deux semaines pour du premier
examen du texte là ce qu'il se passe à
l'Assemblée ça semble être tout
l'inverse l'Assemblée nationale n'a
jamais été aussi utile parce que il y a
de vrais négociations de vrais
discussions le cœur de la démocratie est
au palais Bourbons c'est assez étonnant
est-ce que vous demandiez les gagnants
il est possible que LR arrive à dire on
a réussi à faire passer notre réforme
alors même qu'on n'a pas gagné des
sélections en tout cas moi j'entendais
hier j'ai karoussi vraiment les
sénateurs le problème c'est on en
parlait pas mais il y a aussi des un
émiettement
au centre droit on va dire ça et j'ai
aussi entendu Charles de Courson hier
vous l'avez entendu oui
centre droit et qui se positionne même
centre droit et vous le savez c'est il
est reconnu comme un des sages de
l'Assemblée Parlement
bien utiliser des termes hier que moi
j'ai trouvé étonnant dans sa bouche
celui de déni démocratie et voilà je dis
ça parce que Charles Le Courson c'est
pas un brûlot c'est pas quelqu'un qui
vient pas en cravate à l'Assemblée
nationale
dans les colonnes du Figaro la plus
fédérateur des opinions voilà et s'il
dit ça c'est qu'il essaie et donc c'est
un peu ce que il essaye de de capter
quelque chose de l'opinion de ce
mouvement qui dit il y a une parole qui
s'exprime comment on arrive à la
retraduire comment on arrive à la
retraduire et non pas à se comporter
comme là les manifestants des gilets
jaunes à ici considéré Emmanuel Macron
c'est-à-dire un sourd j'ai une dernière
question Bruno palier puis dans un
instant Christophe Cornavin du service
société du Figaro ne rejoindra on se
penche rapidement sur ce qui peut se
passer demain à l'Assemblée nationale
avec l'utilisation
probable du 49-3 qu'est-ce que ça
changerait est-ce que cela aussi ça
pourrait laisser des marques première
chose à la rappeler le gouvernement
prétend ne pas en avoir besoin vous avez
raison comme faire et encore tout à
l'heure à la sortie c'est vraiment et
il y a pas que de la méthode Coué
puisque on est dans ce qu'on appelle
science politique Indila du prisonnier
c'est que je sais pas ce que mon voisin
va faire et donc j'essaye de
l'influencer par un certain nombre de de
discours donc on verra demain
effectivement mais je pense qu'il le
décideront à la dernière minute de
savoir
ce qui est clair c'est il y a un fil des
choses c'est si ça passe avec un vote
normal
certains leaders sont Colombie je pense
qu'une partie des Français diront on a
perdu au sens au-delà on a perdu ils ont
gagné de ce que pensent les leaders
syndicaux et de la suite voilà c'est ça
c'est quand même ça fait réfléchir dire
bon bah c'est vrai que ça a été voté il
y a eu la prise en compte de syndrome de
choses donc peut-être que ça peut en
partie
résorber une partie du ressentiment moi
je parle le 49,3 c'est une autre affaire
le 49.3 il est vraiment
vécu comme présenté comme les
commentateurs comme le passage en force
parce que je n'ai pas de majorité
sûr c'est du kit ou double je crois que
ça s'appelle la roulette russe en ce
moment dans le langage des commentateurs
et là vous savez très bien ce que ça
fait ça fait que les les syndicalistes
se sentent renforcés dans l'idée je peux
continuer parce qu'ils ont donc il y a
une reconnaissance de la légitimité et
du côté de l'opinion publique il y a
aussi l'idée du passage en France moi ce
qui m'intéresse de dire c'est que on ne
comprend pourquoi on en est arrivé à un
moment où le troisième scénario n'est
même pas discuté qui celui du retrait
ah vous y croyez encore j'y crois pas
mais je trouve intéressant
là on n'est pas faire des prédictions
comme vous l'avez dit on est discuté de
la situation politique et moi ce que je
trouve intéressant c'est de dire un il y
a déjà eu des retraits
et ce qu'on oublie ce que les
commentateurs oublient c'est que
Emmanuel Macron lui-même a fait des
retraits sur les gilets jaunes il a
retiré la tax sur les taux de CSG pour
les retraités il a fait il avait annoncé
qu'il éliminerait 120 000 fonctionnaires
il l'a pas fait c'est 8000 je crois
quelque chose comme ça et je disposa de
fin je peux en citer à peu près une
dizaine est-ce que ça l'a tué est-ce que
il a pas sur bondir non donc qu'est-ce
qui a créé cette ambiance de dire il ne
peut pas reculer vous voyez de mettre
quelque chose pourquoi il peut pas
reculer parce que c'est finalement le
seul réforme de sa campagne
présidentielle
c'est lui qui a construit c'est lui qui
a construit cet engelin de dire c'est du
kit ou double quelque part Emmanuel
Macron s'en fiche un peu parce que la
prochaine fois il sera pas là il sera
plus mais j'imagine que les députés qui
vont voter cette réforme dont ils savent
qu'elle est très impopulaire résonne à
un peu plus long terme que simplement
leur image dans l'histoire merci
beaucoup Bruno palier merci de nous
avoir accompagné je rappelle que vous
êtes directeur de recherche
CNRS au Centre d'études européennes de
Sciences Po et puis auteur d'un livre
réformer les retraites on peut retrouver
aussi votre rapport hein c'est ça sur la
note sur la grande conversation de Terra
Nova qui s'appelle les conséquences
politiques vous pouvez retrouver ça dans
le dans le chat et celui de YouTube on
fait un petit détour par le Sénat parce
qu'il y a les questions au Gouvernement
cet après-midi vous les voyez en bas à
droite tiens est-ce qu'il y a des
questions sur la réforme des retraites
on jette une oreille et puis on revient
en plateau dans un instant
ils sont sales c'est bien fait pour eux
je me demande pourquoi Nestlé ne prend
pas la parole pour dire que ses employés
ne sont pas responsables de ce drame
début janvier après une fermeture
administrative et le tatouage complet du
site les activités reprennent mais les
commandes les commandes ne sont pas au
rendez-vous la direction suspend la
production et arrête la fermeture du
site voilà monsieur le ministre en
quelques mots la détresse que vive
depuis 12 mois les 15 employés de ligne
de Caudry la même semaine on annonce la
fermeture de l'usine Tereos à
escaudoeuvre avec de nouveau 150 emplois
menacés cette usine produit du sucre une
des filières de chances françaises mais
à force d'appliquer de façon drastique
plus drastique que nos voisins les
normes nous sommes en train de détruire
notre filière betteravière alors que le
gouvernement parle de
réindustrialisation des territoires
malheureusement je peux d'avance vous
annoncer que d'autres fermetures vont
suivre
sont des normes coups de massues pour le
cambrésil et codés territoire des gens
en grande difficulté aussi Monsieur le
Ministre quels moyens entendez-vous
déployer pour sauvegarder ses usines
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre déléguée en charge de
l'Industrie Monsieur Roland Lescure de
la parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur wanted d'abord
merci d'avoir rappelé
je sais pas si vous avez des questions
comme ça les questions au Gouvernement
au Sénat en hémicycle presque plein
c'était pas une question sur la forme de
retraite mais on reste évidemment très
attentif à ce sujet Comment ça va
Christophe ça va Thibault et vous très
bien rédacteur en chef adjoint au
service société du Figaro spécialiste
des questions de de sécurité il y a là
la lassitude chez les manifestants sans
nul doute sans nul doute a priori on
s'attendait ça pourrait être
effectivement le l'ultime baroud
d'honneur des des syndicats avant le
avant le vote
de la réforme demain à l'Assemblée donc
les services de renseignements
attendaient entre 650 et 850 000
manifestants une fourchette assez large
mais parce qu'en fait on a eu des
mobilisations en dent de si on se
souvient que le 7 le 7 mars dernier le
mouvement avait fédéré plus de 1,3
millions de personnes en revanche c'est
le record de cette record
samedi dernier
on plonge on est à 370 000 donc là les
services ça n'est pas trop exactement
il pensait qu'on pouvait avoir un retour
quand même de flammes de mobilisation
avant le vote ce qu'on voit clairement
dans les rues aujourd'hui c'est que le
sursaut n'est pas du tout au rendez-vous
à midi il y avait
82000 personnes versus 200 000 le 7 mars
on va prendre le 7 mars parce que c'est
un jour en semaine et voilà
et dans les grandes villes c'est presque
l'effondrement dans certaines
moi je on m'a dit à Marseille on est à
7000 personnes contre 30000 le 7 mars
c'est à dire que on est quand même à
trois fois quatre fois c'est un quart de
la fréquentation d'accord à Nantes on
est à un tiers 13000 contre 30 je vois à
Rennes à 75 contre 19000 alors que c'est
des villes en plus normalement qui sont
quand même des Terreaux de l'ultra
gauche des villes qui sont
particulièrement remonter contre la
réforme des villes où il y a des
incidents manifestes et où on est une
culture de la manifestation une vraie
culture de la manifestation et même il y
a eu encore des incidents encore
aujourd'hui même s'ils ont été
toutes les infos sur le figurant voilà
une autre vidéo voilà texte à Nantes et
vous avez tout mais même dans les
petites villes c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
on a toujours on a beaucoup parlé
pendant ces 7 journées nationales
d'action les 7 précédentes notamment de
cette fronde de la France des
périphéries qu'on a aussi appelé la
France des préfectures et des
sous-préfectures
et bah virage
toujours dans la Creuse alors Guéret
dans la Creuse gardons en mémoire que le
7 le 7 mars dernier il y avait 6700
manifestants et là on est à 1900
d'accord
je le vois d'à peu près 13000 habitants
donc c'est hier qu'on est quand même
vers une une a repris une déflation
particulièrement spectaculaire je vous
avais pas parlé d'Agen mais agent c'est
pareil par exemple
1500 contre 4008 on va pas continuer en
fait en gros on a compris que aussi bien
dans les bastions protestataires
historiques endurcie où il y a les
mouvements les plus radicaux sa chute
dans les grandes métropoles chute mais
aussi dans le reste du pays sa chute
aussi c'est à dire qu'on a une forme de
lassitude pour répondre à votre question
alors la lassitude elle est liée au fait
qu'on est à la huitième journée
nationale qu'on voit que finalement le
gouvernement n'a pas l'air de vouloir
reculer beaucoup que les gens ont
ne touchent plus d'argent depuis huit
jours
c'est quand même un des salaires en
moins et puis il y a une forme de
résignation parce que
déjà la douche froide c'était samedi
dernier quand on s'est rendu compte que
le Sénat a voté le texte en tout d'un
coup ça quand même
et on s'est rendu compte est-ce que vous
ne voulez pas certaines personnalités
politiques de gauche il disait on ne
veut pas qu'on vote le voter le texte
l'article 7 à l'Assemblée pour que les
gens n'aient pas à recevoir vous savez
la petite alerte l'article 7 et voté qui
aurait mis un petit coup au moral des
des de certains manifestants et que ça
dit bon c'est terminé on y va pas quoi
mais en fait je sais pas si on a eu
besoin de cette alerte ou pas parce que
en fait je discutais encore avec des des
responsables des services de
renseignement puis observer un truc
assez particulier samedi dernier c'est
que
à la différence de tous les épisodes
précédents la société civile n'est pas
au rendez-vous
ces petits euh ces gens ces petits
commerçants là on a été véritablement
dans quelque chose d'archétypal au
niveau du des syndicats il y avait la
CGT les grandes organisations étaient là
mais en revanche
le français en colère je dirais rester
chez lui Christoph on peut expliquer
vous tenez vos infos de qui du ministère
de l'intérieur c'est ça le service de
renseignement qui alors les sources
ce sont des gens qui sont qui sont dans
les services de renseignement alors et
ses services de renseignement c'est qui
c'est des
pardon des espions enfin que non non
c'est pas du tout des espions c'est des
agents de police
de la de la police nationale qui sont
qui sont donc spécialisés dans une
filière qui est celle du renseignement
vous voyez moi avec mon j'ai regardé le
bureau des légendes
on n'est pas du tout dans une logique
d'espionnage on est d'accord dans une
logique d'analyse d'appréciation
généraux au pire que on est plus simple
plus comme ça ça s'appelle le
renseignement territorial c'est en fait
on a rebaptisé c'est les c'est les
nouveaux RG entre guillemets c'est des
gens qui ont des CAP de plus ou moins
forte intensité c'est à dire qu'ils sont
en lien avec les syndicats ils sont en
lien avec les élus locaux ils ont
eux-mêmes des des agents qui sont dans
les manifestations et donc et donc ils
croisent un certain nombre de données ça
leur permet d'avoir une lecture
généralement
de savoir vous me dites les chiffres qui
sont donnés d'ailleurs des chiffres hier
de prévision c'est juste pour avoir une
prévision et mieux encadrer si vous
voulez une manifestation il y a quand
même une question de surveillance donner
au gouvernement une tendance sur
l'opinion etc quel est le vrai puisque
ça peut inquiéter les gens voyez de se
dire on est surveillés des gens des
forces de l'ordre essaie de savoir ce
qu'on veut faire alors en fait il y a
pas en fait il y a pas de
veut pas me faire la poutre forcément de
la police nationale mais je veux juste
quand même rappeler de choses deux trois
choses importantes la première c'est que
il n'y a pas de de surveillance
individuelle ou les renseignements
généraux enfin le renseignement
territorial comme tous les services de
renseignement en général ne font pas en
tout cas pour des pour l'analyse des
mouvements sociaux de de surveillance
individuelle sauf pour des gens qui se
sont illustrés dans des faits de
violence contre agent de force de
l'ordre des gens qui sont dans des Black
Blocs des gens qui sont des casseurs des
émeutiers potentiels et d'ailleurs qui
peuvent être à ce titre fichier fichier
fichier dans un oufprt attendez dans des
fichiers particuliers mais autrement
globalement l'idée n'est pas de
développer du du Big Brother au cas par
cas sur si vous avez 300 000
manifestants il y a pas 300
000 pas de manifestants qui ont derrière
eux un agent de renseignement avec un
retrouve un chapeau feutre et des
lunettes fumées
c'est vraiment plus d'essayer de
comprendre l'architecture d'un mouvement
ok ça dynamique et voir et voir après
comment les services d'ordre parce qu'en
fait la police elle est elle est
articulée c'est-à-dire que vous avez le
renseignement qui permet entre
guillemets de comprendre de comprendre
ce qui va arriver et après ça permet
notamment au service d'ordre public CRS
gendarmes mobiles compagnie
d'intervention les bras etc de mettre en
place un dispositif qui soit un peu de
nature à être un peu à la hauteur de ce
qu'on attend c'est à dire que dans des
grandes dans des grandes grandes manifs
on va arriver à 12 15000 hommes et après
si on se rend compte que on est en
période de basseaux on va pas déployer
la Grosse Bertha en tout cas en terme de
de matière donc on n'est pas tant dans
des logiques d'espionnage individuel
mais plus dans une logique de de
d'appréciation de de mouvement d'humeur
et de mise en place de
préparation la mise en place d'un
dispositif en haut à droite en bas à
gauche les images dans la rue pour cette
nouvelle journée de mobilisation et de
manifestation on va à droite les images
au Sénat parce qu'il a des questions au
gouvernement on garde une oreille au
Palais du Luxembourg pour savoir si il y
a des questions sur cette réforme des
retraite et ça forcément la semaine
dernière on parlait de blocage
ça a été très marginal non pas forcément
on peut pas dire ce soir en fait l'idée
faut quand même garder à l'esprit que
les syndicats voulaient bloquer la
France
à l'arrêt mettre la France à l'arrêt bon
ça on peut le dire que c'est pas une
réussite non c'est pas c'est pas à
France franchement parler une réussite
là encore donc les les sources dont on
vient de parler on recensé à travers
répertorié à travers le pays
une cinquantaine d'actions de blocage
dites lorsqu'ils appellent dites de
basse intensité
donc et qui réunissait à peu près 2000
personnes c'est-à-dire que on est
vraiment sur des
sur des des parents des filtrage de des
filtrage de de d'axe routier on peut
être sur des microcurs de courant on
peut avoir des des
ports notamment il y avait il y a ces
opérations
peut-être un peu plus marquants
notamment les poubelles par exemple ça
on parle de blocage ou non simplement de
grève alors il y a des comment dire où
on fait brûler les déchets aux alentours
qui sont les incinérateurs
alors oui ça ça peut partir partie des
déblocages mais en fait en gros c'est
tout ce qui est tout ce qui peut
provoquer une thrombose dans le pays
dans le flux de la circulation dans dans
la manière de de de faire du commerce
dans le dans l'hygiène enfin tout ce qui
tout ce qui peut gêner en fait les
pouvoirs publics sont mis en place
évidemment les poubelles font partie en
Grède de l'Arsenal je dirais des des
gens qui sont dans la protestation pour
pouvoir
manifester leurs colères et gêner et
gêner le pouvoir en place d'ailleurs on
a remarqué que cette histoire de
poubelle c'est quand même le sparadra du
capitaine Haddock parce qu'on parle
comme ça depuis 2 jours vous avez
Darmanin est monté au créneau
Hidalgo madame Hidalgo est plongée dans
l'embarras l'histoire pour le
gouvernement c'est que c'est plutôt un
Hidalgo qui prend la foudre que les
membres du gouvernement dans cette
histoire et entre nous choisit je me
demande en quelle mesure finalement le
fait que Madame Hidalgo prenne la
ça n'arrange pas ça ne dévie pas en fait
le ça ne peut pas dévier la colère du du
du des des gens plutôt que sur la
réforme des retraites bon vous me dites
que les blocages sont assez faibles en
revanche il y a eu certaines actions
plus agressives sur des parlementaires
c'est ça ouais alors là on est sur des
choses un peu plus peut-être un
peut-être un peu plus sérieuse et plus
inquiétante parce que ce que ce que
redoute donc les analystes du ministère
de l'intérieur c'est notamment des
actions visant des élus alors des élus
essentiellement évidemment des élus qui
ont la main sur sur le projet de réforme
c'est à dire que les élus qui ne
voteront qui voteront pour la réforme
risque de s'exposer à des à des mesures
de rétorsion dans leur circonscription
et
ça déjà commencé un je moi je on m'a dit
donc des députés ont été la cible de
menaces à Pau à Perpignan à Brest il y a
des sénateurs aux lois en Haute-Loire
udi ou LR d'ailleurs qui ont été privés
d'électricité
il y a une sénatrice du groupe
Rassemblement démocratique et social qui
a elle était quasiment enfermée chez
elle en Meurthe-et-Moselle parce qu'en
fait ils ont ils ont réussi à
neutraliser le boîtier de ça ce que j'ai
compris c'est le boîtier de sa maison et
en fait elle n'a pas pu sa verrouiller
en fait
et
c'était ça pouvait être assez dangereux
et enfin
à Amiens devant le la
chocolaterie trogneux oui
chocolat
donc neveu de Madame Macron il y a les
CRS qui ont été déployés parce que des
manifestants passaient devant parce que
Macron évidemment capitalise concentre
toute la toute la toute la colère des
manifestants et des gens à la tête
devant cette pauvre chocolaterie en
hurlant anti-capitaliste et donc et donc
les CRS sont dû s'interposer
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il y a une
ambiance
délétère et qui risque de qui risque de
s'accélérer pour l'instant Christophe
cornelin parce que Elisabeth borne la
première ministre prend la parole dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat et elle s'exprime
sur la réforme des retraite il y a
quelque chose de dangereux à tenter par
tout moyen d'empêcher le débat de le
bloquer
[Applaudissements]
la gauche sénatoriale la gauche
sénatoriale a revendiqué un seul
objectif empêcher un vote sur le texte
vous n'avez pas réussi de longs débat
ont eu lieu tous les articles ont été
examinés et le projet de loi a été
adopté à une large majorité
madame la Présidente assassin évidemment
j'aurais préféré plus de débats de fonds
et moins de procédures plus de débats
d'idées et moins de posture vous en avez
décidé autrement je le regrette mais
c'est ainsi et c'est le fait unique de
ce qui devient la nuit pêche sénatoriale
[Applaudissements]
je veux
je veux à cet égard
je veux à cet égard celui et l'attitude
responsable de la majorité sénatoriale
pour la bonne tenue des discussions dans
l'hémicycle
pour ma part j'ai le plus grand respect
pour le travail parlementaire qui se
poursuit en ce moment même en commission
mixte paritaire
et je suis convaincu que le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale peuvent s'accorder
pour un projet qui garantira l'avenir de
nos retraites par répartition qui
réduira l'écart de pension entre les
femmes et les hommes qui augmentera les
petites retraites qui fermera les
principaux régimes spéciaux qui
améliorera l'emploi des seniors qui
protégera ceux qui sont usés par le
travail qui permettra à ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt de partir plus
tôt cette réforme est nécessaire elle a
été enrichie notamment grâce aux travaux
de votre assemblée et avec mon
gouvernement nous sommes pleinement
mobilisés pour que dans les prochains
jours une majorité vote la réforme des
retraites je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame
Samantha casse bonne pour le
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la parole
mais madame la ministre des Sports
Elisabeth borne déterminée à faire
passer cette réforme des retraites on en
doutait pas et qui espère et qui croient
pouvoir faire passer son texte sans
l'usage du 49 ans n'en parle dans un
instant avec arméus des Figaro Magazine
je suis toujours avec Christophe
Cornavin William parler de Paris oui
juste de mots pour Paris dire que il va
falloir que mettre assez attentif
aujourd'hui sur ce sur ce défilé
parisien
on n'attend pas forcément un déferlement
de manifestants entre 50 et 80000 selon
les estimations donc on verra les Russes
semblent pas complètement saturé il y a
pas on voit sur l'image il y a pas un
monde et en plus délirant c'est toujours
pareil Christophe l'Espagne des
Invalides c'est vaste pour la remplir
c'est difficile et ça c'est un peu vide
là ça ressemble à quand même même très
clairsemée même si pendant de
précédentes manifestations on a déjà eu
l'esplanade assez assez noir de monde en
tout cas là c'est pas mais en revanche
seront rendez-vous on le sait déjà des
des casseurs la préfecture de police
estime qu'il y a entre 400 et 800 gilets
jaunes radicaux donc des gilets jaunes
vous venez toutes les semaines me parler
de ces casseurs pour l'instant on les a
pas vu ou quasiment pas
on les voit mais ils ne passent pas à
l'action
on a commenté pendant un long moment une
sorte d'affrontement en tout cas visuel
entre
ils sont au rendez-vous et ils attendent
véritablement le
l'opportunité et donc en fait ils sont à
milliers à peu près là normalement dans
les dans les dans les dans les cortèges
et en fait leur idée à eux c'est de ces
d'essayer de de
trouver l'intercice et de et de passer à
l'action
pour l'instant effectivement la
préfecture de police fait attention il y
a eu à là pour l'instant pour vous dire
j'ai eu un message là il y a eu 2800
contrôles qui ont été réalisés en amont
c'est à dire que 2800 personnes qui ont
été fouillées qui semblaient un peu
suspecte pour pour éviter qu'ils
viennent contaminer le le défilé et dans
le lot il y a eu quatre interpellations
c'est rien donc pour l'instant c'est
rien alors en revanche après il faudra
voir ce que ça donne pour la suite
de vous relâcher Christophe qu'est-ce
qui est envisagé vous parlez des
renseignements qui essayent de
s'informer de savoir quelle suite sera
donné au mouvement ça donne quoi et à
quoi on se prépare à quoi on en tout cas
c'est pas les enseignements qui ont
organisé la suite du mouvement mais en
tout cas eux
mais en revanche eux ils ont ils ont des
hypothèses parmi lesquelles l'hypothèse
c'est que ça a pas s'arrêter demain
c'est pas parce que c'est pas parce que
le texte passera passera à l'Assemblée
d'une manière ou d'une autre que ça va
s'arrêter évidemment si on si on si on
brandit l'arme du 49-3 ça va
cristalliser encore plus la colère et
dans ces cas-là ce que pensent les ce
que pensent les analyses c'est que les
protestataires pourraient peut-être
avoir la tentation de continuer le
mouvement pour peser sur le Conseil
constitutionnel si celui-ci
après le vote de la loi mais ça c'est
une chose il peut aussi se dire que
l'exécutif
peut être encore un peu fragile et un
peu encore le travailler en
profondeur pour éventuellement tenter de
ne pas faire ratifier la réforme oui
parce que regardons en mémoire que le
CPE euh
n'avait pas été finalement ratifié sous
la présidence de Jacques Chirac et
manifestement dans les syndicats et
parmi les plus durs des protestataires
l'idée c'est d'entretenir cette flamme
de la contestation pour essayer de de de
faire flancher l'exécutif même si cette
loi passait alors
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
là pour l'instant c'est relativement
calme on vient d'en parler parce que le
le le les syndicats sont encore à la
manœuvre c'est-à-dire que les services
d'ordre des syndicats sont encore à la
manœuvre mais on verra ce que va décider
l'Inter syndicale qui je crois se réunit
ce soir après 8 7 8e journée nationale
d'action mais si d'aventure une partie
du front syndical se fissure et
notamment si les syndicats réformistes
sont plus d'accord on se retire de la
partie tout d'un coup on aura pu se
France syndical et donc la rue va risque
d'être livré à un autre public moins
contrôlé et on arrive on arrive à
évidemment à ce à ce gros spectre qui
fait peur à tout le monde de la grosse
colère citoyenne
et on avait vu comment ça va finir parce
que là on a pas de professionnelle de la
manifestation et et ça peut mal tourner
merci beaucoup Christophe corner je sais
que je dois avoir lâcher vous avez fait
5 minutes supplémentaires c'était le
temps additionnel et vous revenez
évidemment si les manifestations se
poursuivent on ne sait pas
ce sera le cas on va d'abord sur le
terrain esplanade des Invalides Matis
fleuret vous êtes avec un manifestant un
élu
oui tout à fait Thibault alors je sais
pas si vous le voyez là derrière moi
mais on n'a pas beaucoup bougé depuis
tout à l'heure ça avance très très peu
et je suis avec nous endurant rocher et
lui ELV et aussi connu pour être le
sosie de Jean-Michel Blanquer c'est
l'une des enfin c'est la dernière manif
avant le vote à l'assemblée est-ce que
vous croyez vraiment que ça va changer
quelque chose en tout cas ça montre que
nous sommes encore mobilisés et en fait
surtout que les Françaises et les
Français sont très nettement opposés à
la réforme donc la question qui se pose
c'est est-ce que la représentation
nationale représente vraiment l'opinion
des Français sur des sujets majeurs
comme celui des retraites justement à la
CMP il y a une très grande majorité et
pour cette réforme est-ce que vous en
attendez quelque chose et bien moi j'ai
toujours l'espoir que les représentants
de la nation et on vit de représenter la
population française dans son ensemble
et donc face à cette réforme qu'ils
entendent les appels des grévistes des
manifest je rappelle que son quand même
les manifestations les plus importantes
depuis le début du 21e siècle et si le
texte est voté à l'assemblée est-ce que
le combat est terminé pour élever
absolument pas parce que en fait il faut
continuer d'être au côté des
manifestants qui ne supportent pas la
réforme est-ce que en fait tant que le
texte n'est pas promulgué en fait il y a
encore un espoir et donc il faut essayer
de se battre tant que possible jusqu'à
la promulgation du texte et justement
quelle forme ça peut prendre alors
est-ce que c'est encore des
manifestations alors en fait toute forme
non violente nous paraît bonne pour
faire entendre la voix des Françaises et
des Français parce que en fait la
question c'est la question de la justice
sociale mais aussi la question de la
légitimité de la décision et comme c'est
une décision qui n'est absolument pas
soutenue par la population alors que je
le répète le sujet est absolument majeur
on parle de deux ans de nos vies donc je
ne vois pas comment est-ce qu'on peut
avoir une représentation nationale qui
joue autant avec notre volonté et la
volonté de de la population je suis très
inquiet qu'on ait une représentation
nationale toujours plus déconnectée et
que du coup on fasse ainsi monter le
sentiment de colère et moi je suis
évidemment contre la réforme ELV et
contre la réforme mais en plus nous
sommes très inquiets sur le fait que les
Françaises et les Français soient
nombreux à être à bout il y a toujours
de français et toujours plus pauvres et
à qui on demande de faire toujours plus
d'efforts en fait il y a un moment où ça
va trop tirer sur la corde ces formes
non violente est-ce que ça prend en
compte les vieux est-ce que vous
soutenez les les blocages à ELV alors ça
dépend de quel blocage on parle mais à
partir du moment où ils sont nos
violents oui
dont les coupures de courant pour
certains élus ça vous a prouver en fait
les syndicats et de manière générale
ceux qui opère sont libres de leur
manière d'opérer et il sait pas à nous
de leur donner des leçons c'est à dire
que que la politique s'occupe de
politique et que les syndicats
s'occupent de l'organisation ils ont
prouvé quand même dans l'histoire que
ils ont été capable aussi d'aller à la
table des négociations là on a un front
syndical comme on n'a pas eu depuis très
longtemps en France c'est quand même un
signe de la responsabilité des syndicats
je trouve que c'est quand même un peu
incroyable de penser que ce qu'ils font
n'est pas légitime alors que ce qui est
fait en face me semble pas très légitime
non plus et la question c'est où est la
légitimité et ça je laisse les uns et
les autres tranchées mais c'est pas nous
donner le son merci beaucoup pour durant
rocher pour cette interview voilà
Thibault je vous rends la main
merci Mathis fleuret vous êtes
visiblement toujours rester à la maison
valide ou vivant partout c'est vraiment
c'est parce qu'il y a plus grand là vous
êtes calméus bonjour bonjour
la politique donc il y a en magazine
alors ça y est deux jours décisifs si on
aime la politique on est servi hein oui
depuis il y a un mois
on est bien cette situation
telle situation avec le cœur battant de
la démocratie à l'Assemblée nationale
devrait débat parlementaires pas
seulement des députés qui votent ce que
veulent le gouvernement là on a des
débats c'est génial non je vais vous
dire ce qui est rare peut-être inédit
c'est que on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer et c'est ça qui qui crée ce
suspense c'est que vous avez plusieurs
hypothèses aujourd'hui oui la CMP on
s'oriente vers une CMP mixte Paris en ce
moment on s'oriente visiblement un
accord ce qui veut dire qu'il y aura un
vote demain au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
mais que va-t-il se passer à l'Assemblée
et ce qu'il y aura une majorité ou pas
est-ce qu'on va faire le 49-3 ou pas
tout ça ce qui est dans en suspense en
ce moment et et quand on interroge nos
sources que ce soit chez les LR ou à
Renaissance vous avez des sons de cloche
très différentes des comptes très
différents alors ça ça m'intéresse c'est
à dire que
tout ce qu'il faut reprendre dans
l'ordre il y a cette CMP Commission
mixparité
va sortir parce qu'il y a une majorité
en faveur du texte voilà si vous voulez
au Sénat c'est une majorité de sénateurs
LR à l'Assemblée une majorité de députés
Renaissance on sait depuis le début qui
a un accord qui est possible entre ces
deux parties avec le gouvernement les
discussions sont faites très en avront
on a vu là l'article 7 a été adapté en
CMP l'article 7 c'est celui qui fait le
passage de 62 64 ans la CMP je croyais
qu'elle était à huis clos mais on a
quand même les échos qui sortent ça y
est là
on est en direct pour tout vous dire
mais vous m'apportez une information
d'accord donc ça y est au fur et à
mesure on l'append sur Twitter il y a
les articles sont sont votés donc je
crois que même celui sur les carrières
longues a été voté et c'est là où c'est
intéressant c'est qu'apparemment
intégrant les amendements de d'Olivier
marnex sur les 43 annuités on va voir le
contenu exact mais ça ça permettrait
peut-être de débloquer les choses à
l'Assemblée nationale d'accord bon alors
un texte va sortir c'est quoi dans la
soirée oui dans la journée là oui oui
bien sûr ça sort demain matin votre
Sénat formalité techniquement oui il y a
eu un vote ce week-end une majorité de
sénateurs la beauté le texte va pas être
détricoté avec les la CMP il va être
aménagé il y a des choses qui vont
bouger mais la philosophie générale du
texte et d'ailleurs Bruno Retailleau l'a
dit ce matin quand il était invité sur
terre voilà il va voter ce texte c'est
un texte dans sa philosophie générale
qui est le même que celui que les
sénateurs adoptait en projet de loi de
finance de financement de sécurité
sociale quand il disait voilà donc au
Sénat pas de problème l'après-midi
Assemblée nationale alors option 1
est-ce que c'est ce que dit le
gouvernement aura pas de 49-3 on va les
croire option 1 il y a un vote mais la
majorité n'est pas majorité absolue il
faut donc aller chercher des voies
comment ça se passe très précisément
est-ce qu'on appelle député par député
ah bah oui là vous avez tout le monde
est mobilisé mais non mais vous savez
c'est ce que faisait Michel Rocard de 88
à 91 ans
vous étiez trop jeune non j'étais même
pas mais pour tout vous dire voilà la
série Baron Noir avec Kad Merad qui va
chercher voix par voie mais oui
là-dedans c'était impossible ça n'a
jamais existé des années 80 c'était plus
facile dans les années 80-90 parce que
il y avait voilà des ce qu'on appelait
les fonds secrets de Matignon il y avait
la réserve parlementaire donc on pouvait
agir là c'est plus possible il faut le
faire presque un visage découvert mais
vous pouvez promettre de passer des
amendements à un député ou un sénateur
dans un prochain texte vous pouvez
prendre des attentif à ce qui se passe
dans sa circonscription sur des choses
comme ça voilà il y a tout un tas de
leviers qui peuvent être actionnés par
exemple je sais pas on peut appeler un
député lui dire écoute
prochaine élection on n'est pas de
candidats face à toi je sais pas ça peut
être ce genre de chose ça peut aller
jusque là on est loin d'une élection oui
c'est vrai vous savez en politique
Charles Pasqua disait les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui les reçoivent
voilà mais vous avez plusieurs leviers
c'est à dire vous avez d'abord le patron
du groupe LR on peut appeler c'est
députés le problème c'est que chez LR
vous n'avez pas de consignes de vote oui
parce que vous êtes libre
les députés qu'on appelle ce sont des
députés LR qui pour l'instant sont un
certain quasiment peut-être ceux de les
indépendants mais la plus pour que le
texte passe il faut que le groupe LR le
vote dans une proportion de 40 pour et
maximum une vingtaine qui soit votre
compte soit ça le ciel